playboy has a new cover
guess they have a new cover every single
issue
playboy
you know when i was younger i would read
it for the articles you'd always read it
for the articles but i i have not seen a
playboy and i don't know since i was a
teenager or something i don't know i
don't even know it was really still
around it seems like so dated now in the
era of the internet and the era of
pretty soon we're gonna have like
hologram porn stars walking around our
society so playboy seems a little
outdated they're trying to get i think a
little more excitement and a little more
publicity and so what have they done
they've put a man
on the cover of their magazine
they've got this guy i think he's a
filipino guy
he's like a social influencer i don't i
don't know his name i'm happy to say
there's now a man dressed up as a woman
in a skimpy little bunny outfit on the
cover of playboy
a lot of people are looking at this and
saying
this is crazy
oh my gosh it's the inversion of play
but the whole point of playboy is you
have hot naked women and then men
pretend to read it for the articles but
they're just looking at the women and
now you've got dudes on there that
doesn't make any sense does it i
actually think the people who are
criticizing this decision are missing
the point i think it makes perfect sense
i think it is
intrinsic in the logic of playboy and
the playboy philosophy
that eventually you'd get some dude in a
skimpy outfit dressing up like a woman
on the cover of the magazine there's a
great episode of firing line william f
buckley junior's old show where it's him
and hugh hefner
back in the early days of playboy
debating the playboy philosophy
okay
and it's really worth watching because
you see these two guys
and you you really see two different
ways of life you've got buckley who's
kind of urbane and laughing and
you know
educated and restrained and you've got
hugh hefner
who
looks nervous and he's jittery and he's
he just looks kind of creepy and he
sounds kind of creepy and he's obviously
not even close to his intelligent or
educated and they're debating the
playboy philosophy what's the playboy
philosophy
give yourself bodily pleasure
that's the philosophy give yourself
bodily pleasure so if
if
the
world
every consideration that we have to make
about how we behave in the world only
runs skin deep if it only comes down to
the flesh
then why would you
not have a man who looks kind of like a
girl on the cover of your magazine
that's for girls
if there's no difference
if it's just meat right if it's all if
it's just flesh if it's just body then
if a guy looks kind of like a girl
why
why would you not have him on
there's no spiritual difference there's
no metaphysical difference it's just
physical
so one yeah he looks like a little bit
of a weird guy he doesn't look like a
total normal girl not like a busty buxom
playboy bunny but
he doesn't look all that masculine
either he looks kind of effeminate so
sure why not put him on
why not what's the difference
if you take a view of sex that is more
traditional christian jewish muslim
pagan for that matter i guess uh you
know
if you take a view of sex that is not
purely materialist
then you might say well it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter if the guy
undergoes surgery and looks exactly like
a woman you still shouldn't put him on
the cover of playboy but if you're if
you're a materialist as the playboy
philosophy would have you be
makes perfect sense go enjoy your
go enjoy your dude on the cover of
playboy
materialists i'm so glad you like that
clip if you want the whole episode you
can subscribe here you know ring the
bell hit the smash do the whatever i
don't know on youtube you can do that
that's fine but if you want the full
show without any of the big tech
censorship i would go check it out at
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your podcasts you
can subscribe for free to the michael
knowles show we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]
you